hello everybody my name is Mark Lauren
welcome to the bean boozled challenge I
have a special guest here his name is
Brian
hey guys yeah hi Brian you've been
through improv like every level of
improv class of junk not even it is
quick and rhyme him out of here too so
we made a horrible mistake of getting
this big master set of bean boozled I
can't even really show it to you guys
give it snow is tough to be brave as the
leader I'm gonna go first here we go
caramel corn or moldy dude molding shows
or cheaters come I was gonna say are we
gonna pop invite
how'd you well it doesn't taste terrible
I'm gonna assume that that was caramel
corn
come assume was pretty [ __ ] great
yeah hey Pig we gotta I want to preface
this lion is terrible it illogic good
have a lot of things we terrible at some
things not terrible at a lot of things
he laughs a lot he loves to laugh he
loves too much more thanks a lot he's a
lovable [ __ ] I he has a horrible
horrible horrible gag refill flash but
wait what's the catch
oh that's right Ryan is probably good
about it and then Matt has a deathly
fear of vomits called emetophobia and I
am oh I'm terrified so what happens when
you see Bob like what what can we expect
you I just get very scared so what I
would love is if
vomit and spirit abana you were also
scared about it so myself
I'm gonna spin this in the many will
count a chump
sounds good okay looks like very caramel
corn moldy cheese again alright Cheers
who needs to nab all the good care of
recordings you know your goal good I
feel like I might have gotten a really
mild moldy cheese I have my tasted sweet
I was definitely ready spin it Ryan spin
away
no Borden chocolate pudding can heal any
wound and I've had dog food before three
two one oh come on be a good sure I love
watching you guys suck walk I just do
hard to avoid juicy pear or booger well
Josie is a to know we believe it's right
because you don't keep evenings there
bad yeah exactly
juicy pear is my favorite flavor of
jelly bean so this could go very well or
just add mark booger as your favorite
absolutely already cheers Cheers booger
is really good it's not it's it's really
a lot of you can see how it's all stuck
in my tía it's good you're good okay
good
Wow Oh
putting your candle okay that's the
brown one yeah so here's yes that dog
for that my gosh talk about this it 400
percent dog food Oh down finish
yeah jigs like wait is my pudding I
honestly catch up you know really often
use this ice like rancid beef
student-designed is either really bad
putting a really good dog food that mine
was 100% dogs we got I know I'm
extremely unhappy oh I don't think I
could handle it right after leaves baby
we'll see about that
yes Cheers mmm blonde boom wine it's
only gonna be with Matt even a little
what about you definitely long but you
know what I'm gonna but overall I mean
long for things not terrible if I had
had it what I do you think I would have
probably had a commercial no why would
he just jelly bean again absolutely on
its own we're not going to get vomit
flavor and I'm not sitting this close to
you baby
okay I'm gonna make an executive
decision you have to do the bottom one
no spin it no no no no no no no no might
do them on the one timid yeah why just
yeah we got a second one here once you
speak good - oh yeah are you okay oh
yeah it was bad ah
this is exciting so we're gonna finish
this off big because we made them be
tortured so we have one of every single
flavor in the entire bin we're going to
do it at the same time got it
okay you're right how did Cheers
oh my god no skunk routing it go Oh
Gately oh alright it's not going
anywhere
Oh oh my gosh Tom Goodwin could it like
fade in and out would be good and then
the bag come right is it just all bad I
think I got all the back I'm trying to
breathe my way through this I got it Wow
ok so that was the bean boozled
challenge thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you Brian for
stopping by pretty much i'm ryan for
doing your thing thanks man for having a
phobia of falling good it kind of worked
out pretty well so check out star bomb
ninja sex party now on the game grumps
team officially all those good things
will be in the links in the description
below check out their channel kids with
problems and thanks again everybody for
watching and as always we'll see you bye
bye